I remember the first time I saw this
movie so vividly I was in seventh grade
and I was at a sleepover and it
immediately just became one of my
all-time favorites I'm curious about
guilty but I'm sorry I'm just gonna say
I just feel so guilty because I'm
thinking about these young girls who
went to see this movie and probably
thought holy mother look at those women
I mean it was it's such an adult themed
piece and I just you know I keep
thinking what have I done corrupted the
entire world
no it was so I mean it's such a
spectacle and so dazzling and so
exciting and I mean cell block can go
it's so empowering like one of the best
you know songs of musical theater
history it is a great number I'm curious
what was your first introduction to the
story and what do you remember about it
well you know it's interesting I saw the
original Broadway production with Tito
Rivera on Gwen verden and Jerry Orbach
in 1970 ah and um it was you know so I
was 14. so probably like this you know
in this General vicinity so imagine me
seeing that you know there's something
about it sticks with you because it's so
adult it's so Cutting Edge and uh the
original production was absolutely
glamorous and dark
uh funny
um shockingly
um you know uh you know
um shocking you know in terms of the
sexuality of of of what was happening on
the stage and it was just all of it was
just thrilling and I just remember I was
just so I was such a huge fan of this in
fact when I you know I I went to uh
Miramax at the time
um and they they wanted to see me
because they were interested in a young
director doing rent
and I said um you know I so I went for
the interview and I and and they said
well so what do you think of rent and I
said you know can we just talk about
Chicago because I know you have it and I
know it hasn't been touched and um and I
know people have tried but I have an
idea of how to do it and it was that
meeting that got me the film
so that's how much the show Chicago
meant to me I'm at you know I had this
is you know this is 1975 so I had the I
had the album the record album the lp
and I I just played it out
constantly I could not start so I knew
it it was in my blood
I love that so much and I watched the
commentary with you and Bill Condon last
night and something I was so struck by
was how collaborative this whole process
was and how you would gather so many
teams to conceptualize and problem solve
certain things why is that sort of
approach to filmmaking so important and
you think effective for you well you
know I feel it's it's it's the it's how
musicals work you know and it it you
know it's not maybe not necessarily
always the case with a drama or a comedy
or whatever but when you're you know a
straight film as you as you might call
it with a musical
um you know there's so many elements
involved and if it doesn't come together
in a sort of a collaborative way with
music and dance and writing and lyrics
and orchestrations and all those it's
you know it only works as a team effort
sort of like a collaborative and because
I was coming from Theater which is how
musicals really were born you know it's
so interesting to think that musicals
are really an American art form they're
not anything out there it's and and that
that art form has you know was sort of
uh perfected
on stage before you know before film and
and I and it only works as sort of like
a a machine a unit together and so when
Bill and I worked with John DeLuca who
choreographed with me and and and and
and and John Karen and Fred ABB and our
our conductor and our our dance arranger
all those things it only worked together
as a collaboration that's how it works
otherwise it's all these separate pieces
and it never
you know and it never comes together
yeah absolutely it's so cohesive
um another thing I was really struck by
was just the pure lack of CGI involved
because there's so many amazing effects
like that mirror scene it's just it's
crazy to watch that and there's so like
little of that and it kind of reminded
me of the Mary Poppins returns
featurette with the bathtub and the
slide which I always found so cool do
you think that there's something to be
said about sort of like the magic of
practical effects as opposed to sort of
that CGI approach that is such a great
question I have to say you're 100 right
about that because for me
I try to do everything I can to not use
CGI now of course I'm working on the
little mermaid mermaid which of course
you know it's all you know half of it's
underwater and the backgrounds her hair
her costume frightens everything you
know it's all CGI so there are certain
you know ways you have to embrace it but
I do everything I can on every movie
I've ever done to make it as practical
as possible I think when you're working
in a void against you know against a
blue screen or a green screen you know
the actors somehow are disconnected can
be disconnected you have to work really
really hard to make it sort of
integrated into the performance I mean
when Emily Blunt got on that bathtub
which was just practical and just said
I'm just supposed to go back and slide
down an entire story you know through
bubbles like are you serious and I said
you know what you know I and I just
remember
I think the thing she says is
um what did she say just before she goes
into the tub it's so funny here we go or
something and and I she was she
personally was so scared and excited to
do it and she you know we used the first
take of course because she was just you
know like freaking out underneath but
excited at the same time
and I you know in Chicago thank God we
had so little CGR was coming from
theater I really wasn't aware of how
really to work it you know we only have
some extensions and some backgrounds but
it was all so tangible so real and you
know that made it you know I I feel you
I feel as an audience member you feel
that you can feel was just all fake and
it's just not working so something feels
disconnected so so I always try to do
everything practical if I can yeah
absolutely I think it does I think you
can just tell even if you're not
consciously like aware of it as an
audience member there is a sort of that
little piece of sort of magic
um in there when it is all really done
looking back now do you have a shot or a
scene that you are sort of most proud of
pulling off because there were I'm sure
many that were had their own challenges
I've never I remember when we were
looking at the credits at the end of the
movie
um I remember
my editor turned to me and said well you
know what image because we did a series
it was like of images under the credits
they said what image would you like
under your card you know and I said well
I love the Roxy number where because
it's all just in a black void with a
black sort of mirrored floor she's this
tiny little little you know figure in
the corner and it's all sort of a void
with black shiny black and it just I
know there's something about that that I
just thought this feels so cinematic to
me when I was filming it I just thought
it felt like I'm almost hearkened back
to like the Fred Astaire Ginger Rogers
films with that black shiny floor and
and her in white but I you know that
whole number for me
um
was thrilling to create because it was
it was complicated it was all done with
mirrors and and
um but I loved you know I I always try
and find a hook into a musical number
for myself and I always comes from the
actual material itself you know so she
sings a song called Roxy about herself
it's the it's the height of narcissism
she's talking about how much you love
yourself I know she loves herself and
wants to be a celebrity it's like you
know Kim Kardashian on speed you know
it's like that it's like you know it's
sort of like that and so she
um because that's it's a satire about
celebrity the whole thing and so and I
thought you know it could be all about
mirrors and looking at herself and
loving herself and sliding down a mirror
and and so as soon as I had the mirror
idea that came from the actual subject
of you know of the actual material then
the whole number just came into place so
that that number in particularly
problems yeah I I can see why it's a
really great number really great
decision on that front
I know that you once said If This Were
sort of cast in the 60s or the 70s
perhaps like a Shirley MacLaine or a
Goldie Hawn might play Roxy if you had
to cast Roxy and voma today who would
you sort of be looking at to potentially
put in those roles well you know
I love Emma Stone
I've worked with her on stage in Cabaret
in on Broadway yeah
um she just see she just immediately I
think of Roxy would somehow be hers I
think you know what I mean I just feel
like she could play that and for the
vulnerability you know it's not it's not
it's not easy actually to find
actors who are truly vulnerable that can
project vulnerability the way Renee
Zellweger was able to or the way Shirley
MacLean was able to you know he's a
fragile character that actually kind of
turns during the piece to become sort of
a ferocious person you know aggressive
person and then back down again you know
it's all about the rise and fall of Fame
so Emma Kim comes to mind it's you know
it's it's always
gosh Velma
I haven't really thought of I mean Elm
is a tricky one because you really have
to be a killer dancer for that too I
mean there's some fabulous actors out
there let me think about that one I
haven't
I'm sure it would be somebody fantastic
I mean I think you know what I think we
could cast it now because I was thinking
that saying before actually that you
know we were sort of the Resurgence of
musicals live action musicals very
unusual at that time to do a musical all
the animated musicals were happening but
no one wanted people sing in real life
yeah so I feel like because so many
musicals have since happened right and
so now there's more musicals more people
are singing in film more people are you
know what I mean more people are dancing
in film and so you go oh okay you know
when I was casting
Chicago it was few and far between it
was like let's see if who can do this
you know not many people but I think now
I'll actually be we could we would be
able to cast it 100 I would definitely
watch the Emma Stone version
um and it's crazy because this was like
your first big you know feature that you
did direct if you could go back and give
yourself advice now knowing what you
know now what would you want to sort of
tell yourself going into it wow that's
such a good question
um
foreign I think I would say uh
you know it's almost like it's it's
almost like I would say don't
um do what you're doing don't don't
because I I tried not to look left and
right and I think that actually helped
the film because I never thought about
the success of the film I never thought
about that and so that it's a funny I
know it's a weird answer but it's almost
like do what you did because you're not
aware of you're not thinking about the
success the this that you're just
focusing on telling the story it's
almost the opposite I think I would tell
my younger self to always keep telling
myself now just continue to do that kind
of thing do do it for Do It For the Love
of it for the work for the for the story
and and let everything else go so in a
way the naivete that I had as a director
was helpful and it's something I
actually with each movie tried to hold
on to yeah that's so interesting but
that makes so much sense and then
obviously you've gone on to do many
other amazing you know musicals with
into the woods and now Little Mermaid if
you could pick any of them to adapt you
had your pick um besides the one you've
already done or working on now
um what would you want to tackle next
gosh you know that's always the the
question you know it's and it's
something I haven't really you know I
here's here's what I'm bad at that I
wish I were better at I wish I were
better at developing something while I'm
working on something else but I never
because this remember that I'm just
finishing up now is taking four and a
half years of covet just kind of you
know came right in the middle of it we
were a week away from filming and we
shut down and then we had to come back
up again so it's taken and it's a very
it's the most challenging film I've ever
done because the visuals and how to
create that I mean just even every
moment of the entire film is
choreographed because it had to be
um because there's no
there's no gravity that's right how do
you do that
but um so and that was crazy I mean to
figure out how how we do that so I have
to say that I'm now actually looking
forward to answering that question in
the next few months like when I finish
up this film we'll be finished probably
the end of March it'll be fun to sort of
say well where do I want to go next what
world do I want to be part of you know
do I want to be part of
you know where do I want to go and I try
not to repeat myself you know I I
probably could have done Chicago two
three and four but I was I was excited
you know coming off of that film to go
and do memos of a Geisha as an example
and just kind of go to a whole different
culture in a different place and
different kind of actors and so it's all
you know because you it's your life you
spend so much time working these things
you want a different experience so yeah
um I don't know what that's going to be
it's a very good question but I'm
excited to find out I'm certainly
excited too whatever you do next
um you've said before that part of the
reason you think this musical is still
so popular is its themes of Fame and
also True Crime which I think is more
relevant than ever with like the Dahmer
series on Netflix and all the murder
podcasts in a way do you think that
Chicago was sort of ahead of its time
because the story is you know like a
century old now you know it's funny
because it was written in the 20s as a
satire of what was happening actually
then and it was a Broadway show on about
the satire of the press and and and
celebrity and and you know and criminals
becoming celebrities and what's weird is
that it's never really changed yeah I
remember when we started filming Chicago
it was the beginning of reality
television people were becoming stars
for who had no Talent whatsoever
so and he thought wow there it is you
know Fame at what cost Fame for what you
know and I think in in our fascination
with Fame in creating these sort of
famous people out of nothing and you
know or and so it's what's funny is that
it's been actually pretty much a part of
our culture for all this stuff and it
hasn't really changed yeah in fact as
you just said it's actually become even
more prevalent it's everywhere you go
you know what I mean so you can become
famous for the stupidest thing
but but it's all about that you know
it's that 15 minutes of fame yeah I
think it's more like five minutes and
then people on to the next yeah five
seconds five seconds on Tick Tock of
Fame pretty much yeah that's it yeah
well thank you so much it was such a
pleasure getting to see you thank you
and thank you for being so kind about
the movie of course of course thank you
take care